state of decay - wants you to live out
your zombie survivalist fantasy the game
builds on the idea of the original game
but adds new features and improvements
so as we get closer to the game's
release here's a couple of the new
things you can expect in state of decay
- one of state of decay twos most
welcome additions is co-op unlike the
first one you can now live out your
zombie survivalist fantasies with up to
three players you can either join a game
or invite friends into your world I need
help
however guests do have limited
functionality they cannot pickup
missions enlist help or collect
resources for their reserves this means
that all the resources you collect will
go to the hosts
fortunately you will get to keep your
own rewards for helping other players
and whatever loot you collect is yours
to keep vehicles are a key tool in state
of decay - not only are they a great way
to get around fast but the trunk space
allows you to store multiple ransacks
saving you on more than one trip a nice
quality of life changed this time around
is when you park your vehicle in one of
your parking lots you can go to the
trunk and press right trigger to send
your supplies to your house saving you
time running back and forth the biggest
change to vehicles though is fuel
despite there being a description for
fuel resource this was never something
you really needed to worry about in the
first state of decay now every vehicle
needs to be fueled up if you want to go
so it's smart to always keep a gas
canister in the trunk so you don't get
stuck far away from home without any gas
state of decay to allows you to pick a
leader for your ragtag community once
one of your characters becomes a hero
you'll have the option to promote him or
her to a leader this doesn't change a
whole lot but it will unlock a new set
of side missions that have to do with
keeping the peace and getting to build
relationships with other communities
also be careful about who you pick as a
leader mattingly over here brought down
morale because he was bragging about
being a leader grow up Mattingly during
your travels you may come across some
modifications by outfitting different
facilities with these you can improve
productivity or alter the effects of
different sites keep in mind you can
only have one mod installed at a time
and since it takes time to install new
ones
choose your mods wisely it's also worth
noting that when you start your base has
no power this will limit most of your
facilities fortunately if you have a
generator you can power one facility for
a little bit of fuel state of decay to
s3 is the Blood Plague you'll notice
some zombies have glowing red eyes
these are plague zombies and you'll want
to be careful I better keep an eye out
for plague zombies direct contact fills
up this meter and getting it all the way
up gives your survivors the blood plague
those with the blood plague are slow and
useless if not cured they will become a
plague zombie risking further infection
to your community a cure can be made by
finding samples from plague zombies so
take care if you can't make a cure in
time it might be best to exile that
infected person before it's too late
you'll also need to deal with plague
hearts which are these horrible piles of
flesh that create plague zombies similar
to an infestation you'll need to take
these out before they spread out of
control while melee is possible it's not
ideal and you'll want to use explosives
fire and gunshots to destroy them there
are multiple plague hearts scattered
around the map and with each one you
destroy the others become stronger so
prepare yourself whenever you try and
take one out
hopefully this video gives you an idea
of what to expect from state of decay to
let us know what you're most excited
about when you get your hands on the
game and have a wonderful day the creeps
are swarming our home right now